[Music]
for more than two centuries the motto of
this country was e pluribus unum out of
many one that phrases on the official
seals of all three branches of our
government the presidency that Congress
and the Supreme Court it's been engraved
on our coins since the end of the
Revolutionary War out of many one a
country in which our differences mean
less than our common identity as
Americans for centuries this was the
source of our national strength then a
few decades ago that changed with no
vote or even an acknowledgement our
elites jettison the old motto and
adopted a new one diversity is our
strength the new slogans seem to have
the opposite meaning from the ones the
founders wrote our differences they
begin telling us are now the single most
important thing about us the less alike
we are the better now it's possible that
is true the disunity somehow makes us
stronger what's striking is that nobody
has ever bothered to explain exactly how
so in Friday night we asked the question
one of our jobs in this show is to ask
questions that nobody else is asking we
believe that open debate is our
birthright as Americans but we also
believe it produces wiser conclusions so
we did here's the clip how precisely is
diversity our strength since you've made
this our new national motto please be
specific as you explain it can you think
for example of other institutions such
as I don't know marriage or military
units in which the less people have in
common the more cohesive they are do you
get along better with your neighbors
your coworkers if you can't understand
each other or share no common values
well those seem like obvious questions
to us and long overdue questions but
rather than answer us the left called us
names and tried to shut us up you're
racist they screamed as if that were a
response rather than a tactic keep in
mind that this show has argued
consistently and persistently for almost
two years that people should never be
punished or rewarded on the basis of
their skin color unlike the left we
don't believe your DNA is the most
important thing about you each of us is
an individual not a faceless member of a
herd we abhor defining people by race
that's one of the main reasons we're not
liberals but maybe we're being too
literal about this our critics don't
really think we're racists and they
probably wouldn't care if we were al
Sharpton is still a progressive in good
standing bigotry obviously is no barrier
to entry on the Left none of this is
actually about race at all they're
trying to silence us because they don't
want to answer the question and they
don't want to answer it because they
don't have an answer to it think about
that America is a country the size of a
continent with 325 million people in it
what holds all of that together
what's the glue it certainly doesn't
need to be ethnicity or religion but it
does need to be something countries
don't remain united without a reason
what's ours you think our leads would be
staying up late thinking about that
they're not they haven't given it a
thought and they don't want you to give
it a thought either diversity is our
strength they shout it's an inadequate
response from an inadequate leadership
class meanwhile they fanned the flames
of mindless tribalism division helps
them maintain their power even even as
it destroys our country they have no
interest in national unity they have no
interest in the nation-state itself
actually that's merely a barrier to
their advancement but there are a lot of
people including us who still care about
America the nation
and it's worth thinking about why we are
still a country what do we all have in
common what do we all believe what's the
American idea we're gonna explore all
that in the coming weeks and months
because we think it's worth it but we're
gonna start tonight with Christopher
Harris he's the executive director of
unhyphenated America he saw our segment
on Friday and called us up and asked to
come on to talk about it and we're of
course happy to have him Christel thanks
all for coming tonight we think so good
to talk to you again so it's this the
response that we got and I don't want to
belabor it or whine about it but the
response was so telling from the left
when we asked on Friday night is it
really true this new national slogan is
it true that the less we have in common
the stronger that we are and out of that
thinking about that raise the question
what is it that unites us as a country
why are we a country well I had to go
back to my my foundational roots as a
Christian and I had to say
1:33 said behold how good and pleasant
it is for brethren to get to gather
together in unity and the United States
does have a Christian foundation we're
not a Christian nation we're not a
theocracy but we do have our
foundational principles based in
judeo-christian morality and so we had
to come together as one we were unified
as one you had to bring those thirteen
colonies together and you needed to have
something that was going to unite us
that's where we came up together with
the Declaration of Independence that's
where we came together with the
Constitution which was built on the
framework of the Declaration of
Independence that made it clear that we
are all human beings created with
certain unalienable rights and so that's
what binds us together as the idea the
principle of unable rights and so when
you decide to be anything other than an
American in unhyphenated American you're
talking about this unity and there's
nothing beautiful about disunity well I
couldn't agree with you more I just
wonder why the people who have benefited
the most from our society the people
went to Princeton have cable shows or
the people making a hundred million
dollars in private equity the people who
really have a stake and are in the
country ought to be grateful to the
country are so unconcerned it seems to
me with what might hold the country
together going forward shouldn't they be
the stewards of our country shouldn't
they be working to unite us rather than
divide us but they're not why well
there's powers-that-be out there that
benefit from this disharmony that that
they're looking to break things up and
at end of the day once again as a
Christian I know that that there is an
enemy out there who wants to divide us
that's what they that's what he seeks to
do is to divide and so the United States
is a beacon of light to the rest of the
world people come from all over the
world to be Americans to embrace the
American idea of life liberty and
pursuit of happiness and so there's
always gonna be people who oppose that
idea that's just the reality of the
world but when you look around and I
just had a conversation in the green
room with Sarah Carter an interesting
conversation about the fact that her
family came from from Cuba and they did
not come here and she was saying her
mother did not come here to proudly wave
the Cuban flag her mother came here
across the across the the the 90 miles
from Cuba to be an American and that's
what people come here
to do is to be an American that's what
we've always done Tucker until recently
because we've asked people to adopt
American values when they arrive and
when we stop doing that I'm I'm worried
Christopher I don't think this will be
our last conversation on this topic I
really appreciate your coming on tonight
thank you